mark is in traverse city michigan hey
mark welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi rachel how you doing big fans
uh we
meet my wife and i use your principles
and thank you so much for everything
that you've done for
my wife and my family's life first of
all well thank you how can we help
well i'm uh we're my wife and i are in
baby steps four five and six right now
we make about 130 140 000 a year
and we've pulled up a bunch of cash
right now to pay for uh
my first vehicle post uh baby steps one
through uh three and
i'm replacing my beater essentially
right now and we have about thirty
thousand saved up right now to buy a
half ton
pickup truck that we're looking for um
but as you know the the housing market
and the vehicle market are almost
identical on the supply and demand issue
that's having with it right now
and i'm a little leery about trying to
buy a vehicle that i feel
is overvalued anywhere between five and
eight thousand dollars
only to have the supply chain issue get
corrected in this fall do you have any
opinions on uh
the vehicle market right now in regards
to that question
i don't have any opinions that would be
based in fact-only feelings
so i will qualify it with that but as
you've already
ascertained we those of us in business
have observed
that when the factories quit making new
things
the supply of new things was gone
meaning new cars
you can't find a new car certain brands
you can't still can't find them
they've cranked the factories back up
but you still still haven't gotten them
all the way the car lots
and when there's no new cars available
guess what that does it sends all the
new car buyers into the used car market
where the used car buyers already were
now you got twice as many people give or
take chasing the same number of cars
that is going to drive price up
artificially until
the marketplace gets some equilibrium
meaning that the
supply of new comes in again and relaxes
the used
the strain on the used car market
relaxing the pricing i don't know when
that is
i'll give you a wild guess but it's
worth what you paid for it i'm just
telling you i have no idea
i'm going to guess and say by fall
you're going to get equilibrium in that
market
it may take longer in housing but the
the
and specifically trucks i mean mark
honestly my team we were just doing a
deep dive on specific
used section cars suvs
minivans like we've done these studies
and found oh you actually have some
information
no no well just to say that trucks has
been our hardest
um sector of car i don't know how you
would say a political type of car
uh because they're they they do not lose
their value i mean they trucks hold
their value it's like
but not as much not as much but i mean
like it's honestly as we've done
research to find
good quality used trucks we've been
looking around the 25 000
mark and they're hard to find so when
you said truck specifically
for whatever reason that's even more so
because probably honestly construction's
put a strain on them
yeah yeah that's probably it's um the
other side the other side of this coin
is
that i have the current beater that i'm
driving around right now it's a 2007.
um you know i'm having to put a little
bit of money into it to keep it going
and so i'm just trying to figure out
when should i just
you know metaphorically pull the trigger
on buying the vehicle regardless of its
perceived value right now and that's i
guess that's where i'm struggling what's
your household income keep putting money
in
130 140 000 okay so if you overpaid by
five grand it does not end your life
no it does not so you know none of these
are going to end your life so
it's just a matter it's almost like a
game now it's just
you know yeah when do i buy this because
i just want it and by god i have the
money now now that i'm out of debt
um and it's not the end of the world uh
it's not like you know if you were gonna
say you're gonna lose 50 grand making
130 we got to stop and think about this
a long time
but five grand i don't wanna waste five
thousand dollars but five thousand
dollars over the scope of the next
decade really does not affect you
yeah yeah i agree with you yeah so at
some point
at some point the stress is over and you
go i got the money i'm buying it
that's what my wife would say yeah but
you know and i don't know no i'm just
saying i don't i'm not saying that
points today
it might be you say okay i'm going to
drive this thing until the end of august
or until it gives me
one more repair equal to x and then i'm
out of here
because i'm done screwing with this
thing okay you know or whatever you
could put any kind you could put a
timeline on it you could put a money
amount on the beat or repair on it
and let that be your trigger to cause
you to jump ship and go do with the deal
or you could say i'm just waiting on
these dadgum things to come back down
and then i'll do it
you know you could go you can put the
trigger on it wherever you want but
the point is if you really mess this up
you didn't mess up anything bad right
right given your ratios and your overall
situation
so pan back and look at the scope of
your life pan back and look at the other
thing
and go how much longer or you know and
then that that frees you up
to start looking for a reasonably priced
truck
today and at any time you found one
you could just you could do it you don't
have to say i'm not going to be in the
market
right you know like housing market's
kind of crazy you don't have to say
i'm not going to be in the market but
you can say i'm not going to bid up to
50 000
over what those houses are going for
just to get in line with the 43 other
people that are white hot and have the
fever
it's crazy you can say i'm not going to
get in that line but i'm also going to
kind of keep poking around i might
stumble into a deal
i find a sweet little old lady who wants
to sell it to a guy just like me
you know and that's what you're looking
for right and that you know you do find
those things and you don't find them if
you're not out there wandering around
just the what you want to avoid is
getting the fever it's the fever that'll
get you